bonjour philippe-emmanuel y merci d'être
avec nous en direct ce matin sur rtl
france on vient de le voir depuis hier
madrid a étendu de ces restrictions dans
le but de freiner l'épidémie
ce que c'est une bonne solution selon
vous oui bonjour et bien ici aux mêmes
problèmes les mêmes solutions
c'est vrai que comme le souligne votre
reportage est bien le confinement tourne
à la question politique ici entre les
autorités régionales qui sont détenus
plus tôt par la droite et le
gouvernement central qui est de gauche
et donc on assiste plutôt à une guerre
sur les moyens à mettre en oeuvre
il n'en reste pas moins que les
contaminations effectivement explose à
madrid
mais l'élément vraiment nouveau qu'on
peut dire maintenant c'est
qu'effectivement la courbe de mortalité
ne suis pas je vous le disais il ya sept
jours on avait retrouvé des chiffres de
mortalité équivalents à ceux de début
mars
et je vous avais dit que dans sept jours
et bien on aura une tendance claire et
bien aujourd'hui la tendance claire la
tendance est claire la courbe de
mortalité ne suis pas le chemin de la
première vague
alors est ce qu'un nouveau confinement
un général est possible en espagne on a
l'impression que c'est un peu le même
son de cloche partout en europe les
gouvernements avance dans le fou il ya
beaucoup d'incertitude et d'incohérences
vis-à-vis de ce virus oui et bien
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est un jeu à
trois entre la responsabilité politique
entre la connaissance scientifique et
entre le jeu du virus et dans ce jeu à
trois et bien chaque jour donne sa
nouvelle carte et c'est vrai que cela
explique en partie le l'incompréhension
des nouvelles mesures et des nouvelles
propositions qui sont faites alors il ya
un autre problème qui vient s'ajouter à
sa en espagne est le pays fait face à un
manque de médecins à l'heure actuelle du
notamment un fort exil de la profession
depuis des années quelles solutions
peuvent apporter le gouvernement
espagnol à la profession oui l'espagne
ici payent une politique de santé bien
particulière qui était basée sur la
rationalisation des soit il faut
rappeler ici que le système de santé
représente 2% - du pib que la france et
c'est vrai que le modèle qui a été
développée ici en espagne depuis
plusieurs années c'est un peu le modèle
aujourd'hui qu'on veut développer en
france qui est celui des maisons de
santé
ici on a implanté maintenant depuis de
très nombreuses années des maisons de
santé qui s'appelle des caps avec le
tiers payant intégral
et effectivement ça se traduit
aujourd'hui par effectivement une
insuffisance de modèles face à
l'épidémie qu'est en train de vivre à
l'espagne les deux fait ce modèle a
également fait fuir du système un grand
nombre de médecins est aujourd'hui le
système est sous-dimensionné sur le plan
budgétaire et sur le plan effectivement
du personnel vous qui était à barcelone
en ce moment si on devait faire un point
sur la situation sanitaire est ce
qu'elle est comparable à celle de madrid
à barcelone elle n'est pas comparable
c'est à dire qu'effectivement ici aussi
on est sur une croissance du nombre de
contaminations
on assiste pas non plus effectivement
une explosion des taux de mortalité
comme on pouvait s'y attendre il ya
quelques semaines mais la situation est
un peu moins graves à barcelone en
termes de progression de l'épidémie
dernière question rapidement comment on
peut expliquer cette situation générale
en espagne et si on doit faire un
parallèle avec la france doit-on
s'inquiéter pour un possible confinement
total à paris par exemple
alors c'est vrai vous avez raison ici on
a toujours à peu près trois semaines un
mois d'avancé
alors comme je vous le disais ce qu'il
ne fait pas de doute c'est l'explosion
des contaminations
c'est à dire que les contaminations
repris un chemin très important et nous
effectivement nous assistons au niveau
effectivement nos patients à des
contaminations positive tous les jours
par contre on ne retrouve pas la gravité
des tableaux qu'on pouvait voir lors de
la première vague est aujourd'hui avec
le recul qu'on a sur ce qui se passe en
espagne
on voit également que la fameuse courbe
logarithmique qui est mise en avant pour
montrer effectivement la tendance en
termes de mortalité est bien cette
courbe logarithmique au jour
d'aujourd'hui elle s'est aplatie ce qui
montre qu'on n'assiste pas à une
explosion des mortalités en relation
avec l'explosion des contaminations
ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas dans la
même configuration pour la première
vague
merci beaucoup philippe évalue à lui
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin à libéral
à barcelone